we're learning about a fierce battle for
a key town in southern ukraine and
unfolded earlier this month in boze
nensenk over the course of two days
ukrainian defenders destroyed a much
better equipped russian force and chris
libsay went to the town and is now in
odessa chris what happened in this
battle
good morning yeah these volunteers are
filling sandbags bracing for a possible
invasion because russian warships have
been spotted just over the horizon
meanwhile as this war grinds on the
pentagon says more than 7 000 russian
troops have been killed since the start
of the invasion and a warning that some
of these images may be disturbing
in vladimir putin's disinformation war
his own soldiers are victims the
ukrainian army keeps 12 of their bodies
in a refrigerated rail car in
voznessensk the town is offering to
return the bodies to their mothers they
were too young to have wives but the
russian military won't even acknowledge
they exist says this scout codenamed
ghost
russia is treating their own soldiers
like meat leaving them to rot he says
ukrainian troops here came up against a
russian invasion force that was armed to
the teeth with heavy artillery and
helicopters
in a heroic act of self-sacrifice they
blew up the main bridge to keep russian
tanks from crossing
if the russians got past this bridge
there's a nuclear power facility and
then on to odessa they thought they'd
meet little resistance but they were
wrong
so the russians were right over there in
this town on the other side of the
bridge we meet the mayor who walks us
through the rubble and between the
anti-tank mines
they were advancing with tanks mortars
lots of armor and artillery firing
chaotically into the city center
striking a kindergarten and near an
orphanage he says but this is where we
stopped them
an astonishing tale of a sleepy country
town without heavy weapons of its own
who routed a russian battalion
even locals like 66 year old sushenko
nikolai saminovich a retired minesweeper
in the soviet army pitched in what did
you do when the russians were
attacking i jumped out and shot with my
own rifle he says our commander told me
get back in the basement grandpa but my
heart simply couldn't handle just
sitting there
now that same tenacity has helped keep
russian forces from making their way
here to odessa by land but not by sea
that's why these volunteers are filling
up sandbags bracing for a fight because
those russian warships have already
lobbed missiles at some nearby towns
gail
i'm in awe chris livesay they are still
working very hard and you're right those
images were very disturbing thank you
very much